movie's over i'm trying to live my life
and my back would seize up and if
someone wasn't there to help me i would
just fall over
one of the stunts that you did for for
big brother
and i don't even know if you guys were
cooking up the idea of jackass yet
but you you tried with zero
skateboarding skills you tried to drop
in on a half pipe like a 10 foot tall
vert ramp right and you might as well
have just jumped off the deck and
straight to the flat bottom sideways
right on your shoulder because that's
what happened uh it was the most brutal
slam ever and it was just absolutely
fantastic
well my fear was if i under commit i'm
just going to slide down on my back
so i didn't want to waste anyone's time
so i just stepped off the cliff
you didn't waste anybody's time it was
the most brutal slam and and i'd heard
that someone said that
for like years after that that your
shoulder was really messed up from that
slam and that like you had trouble like
turning the steering wheel of your car
like you couldn't make a left-hand turn
in your car because of that
possibly i remember having trouble
driving my car after the
butterbean ko because it gave me vertigo
okay and when i would
lay my [ __ ] my head to the side to lay
down the room would span if i drive
around a curve
the you know the car would spend
so i had to get on some medication for
that it took a while to wear off uh but
it's pos yeah
sure like sometimes you get hurt and
it's tough to drive your car
you
um you told you said that you lost your
sense of smell
yeah i have to be right up on something
to smell it and it's not that great so
my sense of taste is probably compromise
my nose has been busted a few times so i
said that should you attribute that i
believe so otherwise i don't have any
idea
and then there was a point uh that way
where your back was super compromised
right like on jackass 3d we had like a
professional
like uh
what was the guy with the massage table
yeah yeah um he's just a basically a
chiropractor who could
because what my back i blew my back out
at the end of
jackass number two i would just be
walking down the street and my back
would seize up and i'd fall over
after a bit
no no no this is just movie's over i'm
trying to live my life and my back would
seize up and if someone wasn't there to
help me i would just fall over wow um
because i
uh herniated a disc in my lower back and
when my
uh body when these psoas muscles they're
like big sausage muscles
here would detect that
detect pain back there they tried to
protect it
and
they would get really hard
to put up a barrier around it but when
that happened it would just pull me to
the ground
so
what i did is i got on an exercise
regime and found a chiropractor who
would just
stick his thumb right in those muscles
and they would release and after that i
was a new man
and i found a really good i found the
best anti-inflammatory
but
but actually that
diclofenac is so that actually did help
a lot
so
through exercise and the
anti-inflammatory uh it's it's
pretty good now every now and then i
have to get the chiropractor come and
release it but
it's all right
yeah dude